hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
we're going to be talking about stopping
volume in the order flow you know
recently I did a couple videos on
um Market exhaustion price exhaustion
using the actual order flow volumes
and as well as using the other flows
ratios and today's video is sort of you
know on the opposite side of the
spectrum where you're looking at the
decent you know the heavy volumes there
to stop the stop a move that's happening
now before I jump in remember if you
enjoy my videos and find you're learning
something getting something out of them
be sure to subscribe to the channel
click that notification Bell so you
don't miss any new uploads and if you
find today's video useful be sure to hit
the like button for me and leave a
comment sharing you know your biggest
takeaway I love hearing your feedback
um you know if there's something you
want to see me talk about in an upcoming
video be sure to leave a comment there
so your support really does go a long
way in helping me
come up with ideas and uh your questions
are much appreciated so let's uh jump
into today's topic all right let's get
into it so
again you know recently I did a couple
videos on
price exhaustion all right so
and I just talked about the order flow
ratios now there's two types of ratios
there's a ratio balance High ratio
bounds low the ratio bonds High
indicates
um price exhaustion
Market exhaustion taking place and the
opposite is a racial balance low which
indicates stopping volume now do you
need to use ratios to determine that
well no I mean if you're looking at the
actual volume itself you can sort of
determine that however if you're looking
at different markets obviously different
markets have different volume
amounts that they trade so what you
might consider stopping volume in one
market may not be considered stopping
volume in a different Market Okay so
the easiest way to identify it that I
found was by using ratios by
um looking at the actual volumes and
using a ratio of the volume at different
levels to give me a blue number below
the bar if it's a green up candle or
above the bar if it's a red down candle
okay now
there's just sort of go back to
the types of ratios that exist right
there's two types there's ratio balance
highs
ratio bounds lows right price exhaustion
is well ratio bounds High which is 30
and above
now a ratio bounds low which is price
defense
um is a number between basically you
know one and zero I like to use around
um 0.75
and zero it's never going to be negative
okay so it's it's kind of a tight
threshold right you're talking less than
one and zero okay and again the less I
could go is zero it's not never going to
be negative and
you know it's funny because I I have the
default set on my orphos Trader as 0.69
you can see I got it set at 0.71 but
really you know you could get away with
uh 0.75 that's that's a threshold that I
like you know the reason I have it at
0.69 is because I realize as people
started copying my
um Concepts right my order flows ratios
was one of the ways that I was trading
for a long time I still look at it
obviously because it's built into my
softwares they were literally copying
the 0.69 now remember these ratios
these thresholds are not set in stone
you could use whatever you want again
like I said I know some people use one
so it's between one and zero
I like to use 0.75 but I set it at 0.69
because I wanted to see you know these
people really literally copying me
the exact same settings and putting it
on their own software which they were so
but you know I'm not dumb I got eyes and
I could just see at the charts so if
it's
um a number like 0.7 which I think there
was in the euro currency the other day
you know all those guys that are just
blindly copying the other software that
says got it set at 0.69 are missing them
really it's a flexible number ideally
less than one but somewhere around 0.75
and one or sorry n0 so 0.75 and zero
[Music]
um
anyway I'll just keep it there for now
said this one originally had a 0.71 but
you can see here okay so 0.39 0.13 right
these are bullish
um racial bounds lows which indicate
stopping volume at the bottom of this
bar the bottom of this bar right here's
a 0.62 at the top of this bar
now here's a 0.5
at the top of this bar here's a 0.19
right if it's red it's the top of red
candles if it's blue it's below up
candles so remember when you're talking
about stopping volume
foreign
if the Market's not moving
then you get a rational bounds low well
it's probably not going to be very
effective because there's no move to
stop right you want the move right down
into a new low
or into a new swing High
that's where you want to see the
stopping volume here here here
ideally this one just sort of went
sideways before going back up to new
Highs but the whole concept of stopping
volume
price defense is
level being defended a move that has to
be stopped no matter what right I won't
say no matter what but you get the idea
right so let me just show you a better
example here I think there was one in
the euro currency the other day six uh
or six e sort of go back uh probably day
it was
it was probably Thursday
um
yeah like right here okay here's your
pullback right so you know here's an
area where we're going sideways okay and
you get a bullish ratio bounds low
bullish responsible but there's no move
to stop the Market's just going sideways
that this one is a move
that you're looking to stop
right so if it's you know sideways
market right
that's not where you want to use it I
mean what's you know by definition it's
stopping volume but there's no move here
it's going sideways that's why I say
look for it on a pullback look for it on
a swing high or a swing low you know
bonds okay
Market went up tested the high pulled
back here's some nice racial bounds low
indicating stopping volume 1261 you see
the heavy volume down here then it went
up here through these new highs you know
you can see the volume up here 11
75 and the market started to sell off
and it ran into you know price
exhaustion here with the bullish ratio
and okay it did go back up but that's
what I'm talking about here right you
see a 0.06
okay but the Market's just going
sideways
here now again you know you can see
obviously there's probably some
liquidity right here because you sort of
got this one two
you know triple top
but more or less you know the swing high
is just right here it's just going
sideways you do get a small move down
okay you get a bullish ratio here right
0.35 but again it's going sideways at
least here it came up to a new high
well it's an equal high from earlier but
you know double top pulls back then you
get that bullish ratio if this 0.35 was
in this bar here yeah I would like it
you know a lot more
okay but that's not where it's coming in
it's coming in
you know in back in the middle of your
sideways activity
okay so let's take a look at another
market right we'll look at a commodity
Market because you know Commodities and
stock indices in my opinion trade a bit
different in the sense of you know
there's different Market participants
right stock industry is Cash settled
commodity like you know any of the
grains is physically settled right
people that so you have a different
component of Traders right different
Trader set because majority of the
people that are trading
soybeans Wheats
um corn meal they they have to you know
I mean that's literally their job
they're not there is a speculative
component but the speculative component
in Commodities is a lot less than in the
stock indices in my opinion
um so let's just uh take a look at the
soybeans okay just really quick here so
again this is uh you know Friday
let's sort of go back okay so now now
the thing to remember with beans okay
what grains rather is they trade
overnight until you know was that 7 40
then they reopen at 8 30. so a lot of
the stuff you know the volume is a lot
lighter
at in the overnight session
um you know it's more prudent if you're
going to trade Commodities like the
grains trade them during the day session
um you know that's not to say that you
can't trade them at night I mean here's
racial bounds low here the ratio bonds
low right from the high to the low of
the day
um you got a bearish one up here okay
another bearish one you get smaller
pullbacks and that's just the difference
you just don't have that volatility
necessarily at night that you have
during the day but I just find it a bit
easier to trade them during the day
during the day session
so take a look here this was on Thursday
lord of the day stopping volume rallies
up to where price exhaustion up here and
then it sells off to new lows
you know this I would have liked this
one better had it
touched the low but again it's you know
hit a low rallied up I hate I don't like
to call this a pullback because it's
just you know it's a range bar
um
you know but uh
again that's sort of the thing that you
could take into account if you want to
trade it now this was interesting here
this was also on Thursday a little bit
earlier right low of the day stopping
volume started to go up pulled back one
tick lower
and then popped up right now on this one
right remember I was telling you earlier
about the the ratios right 0.69
where is it here right so the default is
set at 0.69
which again these are not lines drawn in
the sand
right so really what I'm looking for is
a number
you know 0.69 or below but
7.75 is really about what I'm looking
for right so if I see 0.7 I would still
take it if I had it set at 0.75
yeah it would still be valid right it'd
still be that blue ratio again it's just
one of those things I I I threw in there
just to see how people were copying it
but
but looking at it I could see 0.7 is
obviously
right next to you know it's one percent
difference between 0.69 and 0.7 but
again you got the 0.5 here but then you
can just see the volumes here right the
108 appearing there at the low now
what is unique about these ratios right
and the stopping volume is a lot of
times you you would think that that's
where the point of control is going to
come in
but often it doesn't because really what
you're taking a look at is how the
volume is trading you know towards the
bottom of the bar
okay the point of control doesn't
necessarily have to be down there right
and sometimes it is sometimes it isn't
right when it is it makes it you know
very visual very easy to see for a lot
of people but
don't think it has to appear down there
so I'm gonna wrap up that video on
stopping volume so I hope you can
see it a little bit better again that's
one of the benefits of using software
that can analyze it for you and
highlight it for you
right because at the end of the day
you know you should be able to do
calculate it just by looking at it and
seeing Oh you know I got 153 down here
that's pretty decent volume for this bar
I got 108 down here that's pretty decent
volume stopping this move so I know
there's some passive buyers coming in
down here
what should you expect if you see
passive buyers coming in at the low of
the day well expect a rally that's what
you should look for right and again it's
not about trying to predict the low it's
just reacting to what you're seeing in
the order flow come in
right I mean the volume the numbers are
there
it's up to you to react to it
so
again if you enjoyed my videos be sure
to subscribe to the channel
and leave a comment in the comments
Below on what you'd like to see me talk
about next so I'll catch you guys all on
the next video bye bye
foreign